In today's lesson,
we will learn more about a promises,
right to suspend performance before a
promissory is breach by examining the case
of AMF versus Mcdonald's corporation
will take the opportunity to better
understand sections two six oh nine and
two six 10 of the uniform commercial
code, which concerns party's
right to adequate assurance,
a performance and cases of
anticipatory repudiation.
First,
let,
let's review the two relevant sections
of the UCC two six oh nine states that if
a promise he has reasonable grounds
for insecurity. In other words,
if it has reasonable doubts that the
other party will will perform her promise,
the promise see can demand
adequate assurance of performance.
This request must be made
in writing the promise.
See if commercially reasonable may
suspend her own performance until she
receives adequate assurance and if
the promise or doesn't give adequate
assurance within a reasonable
time not to exceed 30 days,
it's considered a repudiation of the
contract and the promise he can cancel.
UCC section two six 10 governs what
happens for a repudiation of the contract.
When one party repudiates the contract,
the aggrieved party can await performance
for a reasonable amount of time or
resort to any remedy for breach,
regardless of which option
the aggrieved party chooses.
It can suspend its own performance.
Keep these two provisions in
mind as we explore this case.
So here are the facts of uh,
AMF versus Mcdonald's.
Mcdonald's, the defendant
appellee in this case paid AMF.
The plaintiff appellant some
$20,000 for a prototype,
a computerized cash register.
Mcdonald's installed the cash
register in it's elk grove store.
Four months later,
Mcdonald's ordered 16 more such registers.
Five months later,
Mcdonald's franchisees ordered seven more.
The first registered was to
be delivered in February,
1969 with the others delivered
during the first half of that year.
In February, 1969, the
registers never arrived in AMF.
Moved the delivery's back to July,
1969 on top of this,
the first test unit didn't
test satisfactorily.
At this point,
Mcdonald's was starting to
get concerned at a March 18th,
1969 meeting between AMF and Mcdonald's.
Mcdonald's requested that production
of the registers be stopped until the
parties negotiated performance. And
reliability standards for the machines.
The parties were unable
to agree on the standards.
In April,
1969 the AMF prototype was removed
from the elks Grove Mcdonald's for poor
performance.
On July 29th,
1969 Mcdonald's canceled AMF then
sued for wrongful cancellation,
McDonald's,
Sudei IMF to recover the purchase
price of $20,385 the cases were tried
together. The trial court held
for the defendant. In both cases,
AMF then appealed and the
instant court affirmed.
The question is,
did McDonald's rightfully terminate the
contract per se pursuant to UCC sections
two six oh nine and two six
10 the court held that yes,
Mcdonald's was right to
terminate the contract,
but it took several steps to get there.
Let's go through the court's rationale
by looking at each step of the analysis.
Let's start with UCC.
Section two six oh nine the court found
that Mcdonald's clearly had reasonable
grounds for insecurity in titling it to
demand adequate assurance of performance
under two six oh nine in other words,
Mcdonald's had reason to
believe AMF wasn't going to
perform what conduct should
constitute reasonable
grounds for insecurity.
This is a bit of an open ended question,
but in addition to the failure to
deliver on an individual installment,
a merchants in solvency or even rumors
of bankruptcy might be sufficient,
but what about the UCC section two
six o' nine's requirement of a written
demand?
You'll recall that Mcdonald's never
issued a written demand for assurance of
performance for this.
The court excuses Mcdonald's from the
requirement of a written demand by noting
that the UCC is to be liberally construed
and declaring that Mcdonald's requests
for further negotiation led to a quote
of clear understanding that Mcdonald's
had suspended performance until it
should receive adequate assurance of do
performance from AMF unquote.
Mcdonald's is clearly sophisticated
enough to read the UCC,
so why does the court
have the power to waive?
The UCC is writing requirement by what
right does this activist judge contravene
legislative supremacy?
This decision is not a conventional
application of UCC is two six oh nine
explicit requirement that the
the man be in writing. Moreover,
there was nothing in the opinion that
indicates there was even a formal oral
demand.
Instead,
the court applied to 609 to the parties
routine negotiation behavior and gave it
legal consequence to 609 is already
a section that is replete with fuzzy
standards.
What are ground when,
when our grounds for
insecurity reasonable.
What is uh,
an assurance that is adequate?
When is suspending performance
commercially reasonable?
When his failure to provide adequate
assurance, not within a reasonable time.
The requirement of a demand in
writing was one of the few rural like
requirements and this case dare
to fuzz up this element as well.
On the other hand,
a realist might claim that this is
a victory of substance over form,
especially where the lack
of form was not prejudicial.
The court then concluded that AMF never
provided the assurance that had been
demanded and this failure amounted to
a repudiation under two six oh nine sub
paragraph four.
Thus,
Mcdonald's rightfully canceled
pursuant to two six 10.
Uh,
sub paragraph B ams to behavior.
In this case it was clear it never
gave assurance it was going to perform,
but what kind of conduct should
constitute adequate assurance?
Mere words might at times be adequate,
but in other cases,
adequate assurance might also require
additional forms of consideration from the
promise or such as a bond
or a letter of credit.
Many contractors would be surprised to
learn that by promising they were taking
on an obligation to provide adequate
assurance if reasonable insecurity arises
much less that the adequate adequate
assurance might include taking substantive
action to assure the primacy
of your ability to perform.
Okay.
What was the last step
of the court's analysis?
The answer is UCC section two seven 11.
The sub paragraph one that section lays
out the buyer's remedies when the seller
repudiates the contract,
which includes canceling the contract.
Okay.
Demanding adequate assurance
can be a risky strategy. Uh,
promises right to demand.
Adequate assurance at first seems
to importantly enhance the promises.
Defensive right to assure the
promise doors performance after all,
two six oh nine allows promises to suspend
their own performance even before a
promise or breaches or
repudiates the contract.
And it allows a promise see to force
the promise or into anticipatorily
repudiating their promises if they
can't give an adequate assurance.
But the right to demand adequate
assurance carries considerable risk.
The privacy,
who wants to suspend their own performance
under UCC section two six oh nine
Mustang have reasonable grounds for
insecurity and they must make a demand in
writing,
uh,
demanding adequate assurance and they
must show that they have not received an
adequate assurance from the promise or
if a promissory suspends performance.
And of course subsequently finds that one
of these requirements was not present,
the promises attempted defensive action
will constitute a breach of contract by
the promise see herself.
What starts off as a legitimate concern
about whether the other side will
perform,
can ultimately become a finding that
the promise see herself breached by
mistakenly exercising her two
six oh nine defensive rights.
In other words,
suspending performance or treating a
contract as repudiated for failure to give
adequate assurance might backfire on
the promise. See, making the demand,
maybe the fuzzy likes standards of two
six oh nine are a feature and not a bug
of this section.
The possibility that either side might
end up being held liable after a promise.
He invokes the,
the section might help drive both
parties to negotiate a compromise and it
dampens the likelihood that promises
would overuse the two six oh nine option,
the right to demand adequate
assurance also exists in common law.
Remember that the UCC only
applies to a sale of goods.
So we care about the common law rule
for service contracts and non good
contracting.
Section two 51 of the second
restatement purports, uh,
to state the common law
rule on adequate assurance.
Though it isn't not followed by
all the states. For instance,
New York has not embraced the adequate
assurance doctor and outside of the UCC
article two, but sometimes
we'll apply it to non UCC cases.
For instance, in One New York case
about an electricity contract,
the court was asked whether a party has
the right to demand adequate assurance
of future performance in a
contract not governed by the UCC.
That New York court answered the question
in the affirmative by extending UCC
two six oh nine two the contract by
analogy concluding that the sale of
electricity was sufficiently similar to
a sale of goods and that parties to a
longterm commercial contract,
which is complex and not
reasonably susceptible of
all securities features being
anticipated bargain for and incorporate
it into the original contract.
As a law student at Yale,
I used section two 51 in a lawsuit
against Gel itself during a disruptive 10
week strike in the fall semester.
I helped organize a group of students to
place their spring semester tuition in
escrow,
suspending their performance,
their a promise of pain spring semester
tuition after sending the university a
letter in writing saying that
we had reasonable grounds
for insecurity about the
university's ability to perform its
promises in the spring semester.
The right to suspend your performance
when you have reasonable grounds for
insecurity has a hidden
gem of contract law.
In summary,
let's review the steps in the UCC that
the court used to reach the final result.
First it determined under two six oh
nine one that Mcdonald's had reasonable
grounds for insecurity to make a demand
of adequate assurance of performance.
Second,
it determined that Mcdonald's is excused
from two six o' nine's requirement of a
written demand.
Third,
it determined that AMF failed to
provide assurance, adequate assurance,
and that it's behavior
amounted to repudiation under
two six oh nine four under
two six 10 be repudiation by the seller
in titles to the buyer to remedies.
And finally,
UCC section two seven 11 one shows that
one of such remedies available to the
buyer is cancellation of the contract.
Among everything we learned today,
the key takeaway from this case is that
non written demand for assurance can
satisfy UCC.
Section two six oh nine.